mon fils vous a déjà dit que le gars était
à l'intérieur du camping-car en train de regarder attendre, nous
n'avons trouvé aucune preuve physique
à l'intérieur du camping-car ou de la maison de sa tante où
il ne vit rien Alex Jones
a malheureusement le QI d'un enfant de
dix ans, il n'y a aucun moyen  que quelqu'un
avec le QI d'un enfant de dix ans aurait pu
esquiver deux filles en plein jour et
ensuite les faire disparaître d'une manière ou d'une autre bien
peut-être qu'il n'était pas seul comment pourrait-il
conduire un camping-car s'il a un QI d'
atteignable hé nous  'envisage toutes les
possibilités je ne pense pas que tu
considères mon passé j'entends j'entends ce que
tu dis écoute moi juste tais toi
Rick veste est celui que nous avons besoin que tu fasses
pour moi j'ai besoin que tu te calmes mr.  Douvres,
je comprends que c'est une période incroyablement
difficile, mais tous les policiers en uniforme
de cet État recherchent Anna. Je
ne comprends pas ce que cela signifie.
Ils ont dit qu'il avait couru. Ils ont dit qu'il avait essayé
de s'enfuir. Je ne comprends pas pourquoi il
j'essaierais de m'enfuir j'entends ce que tu
dis je ne raye personne de ma
liste laisse moi juste faire mon travail